all right guys
what's up bang bang bang lunch
bang bang yeah lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich rest of
us just trying to get our lunch money
right
today is a very big day i'm here with
the beautiful intelligent
end birthday girl polina
evilova marinova it's my birthday oh no
it's my birthday don't be today i'm
being very nice today i've been
overly kind all day last night he got
annoyed with me
but he like actively didn't say anything
and i was like man i love my birthday
week
and she looked at me and she said you're
being nice right now because it's my
birthday and i said
i will neither confirm nor deny the fact
that i am being nice because it's your
birthday but yesterday we
went and did all kinds of cool things we
walked 12 miles
we did we walked 12 miles i gave a
walking tour of new york city walked
across the brooklyn bridge
went to uh ground zero went on the west
side highway
i saw a guy carrying a baby who said
hello to me it was really weird but
he's a lunch money viewer yeah probably
uh
all right before i forget block fi
big bad block fight get money get paid
they are sponsoring lunch money now
you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy
in an interest bearing account at block
five go to blockfi.com
lunch money lock fi.com
lunch money i use the product i'm a
super super
super happy user the first monday of
every month i get my interest payment
it's
awesome and i'm an investor in the
business i sit on the board of directors
they
are it they are cool they're the best
they are cool wifi.com slash lunch money
what's up
birthday girl how happy are you i'm so
happy do we not even need to do the show
yeah can we just like scrap all the
topics and just talk about my birthday
and how great i am what's up with lambda
school
okay um she's 21 for all of you guys
asking she can finally drink
what's up with lambda school raised 74
million in venture funding
for its virtual coding school coding
that's a hard word for me to say coding
school where you pay tuition only after
you get
a job tell us about liam to school
anthony i love
it yeah why yeah where's your eye red uh
well it's because it's reflecting off of
your beautiful shirt
you look just so perfect today um
the lambda school is a coding school
like you said
uh they basically are going after higher
education saying look why go to higher
education and take on all this debt
instead you should come here we'll teach
you how to be a is it just
coding right now yeah and we'll teach
you basically how to code
and you only pay us if you go and you
get a job making more money than you
previously made so it's kind of a
low-risk
uh investment you just have to invest
your time
and it's a pretty rigorous course but if
you invest your time you can go and you
get a job
and once you get a job then you owe them
uh
up to a certain amount of money it ends
up being like 17 000 i think
uh but only if you get a job paying more
than paying more than you were
previously making
you had to make at least 50 000. there's
all these ramifications that basically
say like if it doesn't work if it
doesn't actually help you make more
money
then you don't owe them anything so look
74 million dollar series c
uh austin allred who is the founder uh
is a great guy
and i think uh building a really really
cool business uh trevor mckendrick
right who uh who uh planet has met um is
another great guy
uh and so generally i'm i'm a fan yeah
yeah are you yeah i mean i just hope it
works are you gonna sit here and just
say yeah all day i just hope it's yeah
yeah yeah that's from rap songs yeah
oh god i thought you were trying to be
german or
little john yeah remember that hello
remember lil john yeah not little yeah
y'all
all right what's up what's up with the
next one
get money get paid happy birthday to you
all right so happy birthday apple
is apologizing again sounds like someone
else right now
so apple was apologizing after it found
itself
in yet another controversy this weekend
over its app store
wordpress founder matt mullenwag tweeted
on friday that the wordpress app had
been locked out of the app store
the restrictions apple placed on the
company prevented wordpress from
updating its ios
app well the only way that they would
resolve the issue
was to change its app status to include
in-app purchases
because supposedly wordpress being free
didn't have any in-app purchases and
they wanted some
absolutely insane look what we are
starting
to see is apple's been doing this stuff
for a long time no one wanted to speak
out though because apple had so much
power
but now it's almost becoming cool to
actually speak out against the nonsense
right and by the way i'm a big fan of
apple i got all kinds of apple
devices all this stuff i literally walk
around with a watch on my wrist
every single day from apple like i
believe it's a good company i believe
the hardware works
it's awesome but what do they keep doing
the app store stuff
is just this one area where they keep
doing stuff and i just
i'm left scratching my head like why you
have a massive business you're one of
the most valuable companies in the world
yeah you want wordpress's cut
how did you get it to not turn because i
read the internet
and i know magic the camera the camera
yeah you see
i say that now and then suddenly it's
going to be just me okay
that you probably program it that way so
it's just you and i'm out of the picture
tick tock what's up with
that tick tock plans to sue the trump
administration
as early as this week over the
president's executive order banning u.s
transactions
with the popular video sharing app and
its chinese parent
bite dance uh yeah i mean obviously if
they're being banned in the united
states of course they're gonna fight
back they're not just gonna roll over
and be like oh okay fine we'll stop
right okay um they're basically saying
that
his executive order he doesn't have that
kind of well they said that if they
experience a lack of process
right they pay no attention to facts and
they try to insert into negotiations
between private businesses
i actually think they've got a pretty
strong argument in terms of what they're
claiming
the real question though is just does
any of it matter so if you read the
profile that comes out on sundays
you would have known that tick tock's
secret weapon is this woman who's a
former youtube exec
and she's in charge of the u.s
operations and she's done a great job
you should check it out send the profile
read the profile.com
i don't know if she's done a great job
but she's done a great job growing the
platform
oh yeah yeah yeah i mean and i don't
think that her skill set
necessarily does she or anybody else
claim that she's prepared
or has experience dealing with
geopolitical issues like this right yeah
so she's she's been great at product and
growth and things like that hasn't 2020
been so weird
why i mean we got married
i'm kidding i just wanted to joke around
this is how i live my life go ahead
what else is going on cbs why are there
a hundred videos cbs cnn and cnn doesn't
have a good business model
that's literally not facts any other
site also has it
cbs is asking for roughly 5.5 million
dollars for each 30-second ad in next
year's super bowl
the pricing shows how much the nfl is
the king of tv while also showing how
desperate advertisers and networks have
become for live events
so what happens if they don't have it
yeah i don't know the network will let
advertisers out of their commitments if
the game isn't played if the game is
rescheduled then the advertiser would
move with the game
so basically you pay 5.5 million dollars
for a 30-second ad
and that 30-second ad is going to get
during the game regardless is that is
that less than normal
um i think it's about the same yeah huh
yeah oh yeah there's some of the most
expensive ads
but okay don't we think that you know
if there are no fans and there's no jlo
then there's be some kind of discount
well why would there be j no j-lo like
no half-time performance yeah
covet safety no they would still do a
halftime performance if it's not jlo
there should still be a discount
why because jayla's not there what if
it's beyonce
oh no she already did one yes so did jlo
so
now you've i don't think they'd do
another one okay
if it's you i'd pay a premium should we
buy a
super bowl ad oh for the profile
yeah yeah all right give me 5.5 million
actually give me six million
what yeah i need six no yeah 5.5 for the
ad and i need 500k just for
greasing the wheels a little bit what
wheels are you going to grease
i'm going to put a half a million
dollars in my pocket and go to
mcdonald's and buy a lot of we match
perfectly to them okay what's up with
ben affleck aflac
okay first of all aflac
first do you guys see how easy it is to
make her laugh
do you see how easy this is it's ben
affleck
i understand that there's no a no you
said it like the duck on
insurance aflac what is that it's an
insurance company insurance right yeah
the duck
aflac okay so it's ben affleck for the
record i could be a voiceover
guru go ahead let's go ben affleck
okay his film moves shooting to canada
as hollywood abandons us without widely
available
covet testing but so canada has widely
available testing
i have no clue all right hold on a
second so
uh uh it was halted due to coronavirus
they were testing it became quite clear
quickly that it was absolutely
impossible
says the president and ceo of solstice
studios
so rising covet cases in california
forced the studio to look at austin
texas as the new home for the film
those plans quickly dissolved as cases
grew in the lone star state
and it became apparent that the
production would not be able to
accommodate the three tests per
week for actors and crew that hollywood
guilds were required if it remained in
the us
so it's going to canada to basically
skirt
yeah i mean look vancouver's a huge
movie uh
center yeah we've been to vancouver yeah
we have
the problem okay so there's a shirt so
okay so we walked up that big mountain
and then got stuck there because there
was no taxis
oh my god we did it how did we get off
we walked and then we got a taxi at some
point oh my god
see she forgets what i do for her i
protected you in the wilderness from the
bears
they were zero bears they were tourists
yeah
some of those could be bears all right
what's next
all right so that you're going to like
this a california
man used cans of bud light to extinguish
flames from
wildfire what's this guy's name anthony
little
so chad little chad littlest let me tell
you something about life man
you get it you understand bud light is
versatile so let me tell you why he did
you could chug it you could spit it at
people it's
like you know it's like a weapon you
could use it to pour out fire you can do
all kinds of stuff
bud light is versatile so and it's the
best beer on the market
a california man was trying to protect
his home from the lnu lightning complex
fire and he used the only thing he had
to put out the flames
beer so basically as his family packed
up
little made up his mind he wasn't
leaving he was saying and protecting his
home
hold on hold on you gotta tell me what
the quote is he said
it was crazy everybody's on propane
tanks it was like a war zone okay
this happens and i'm like nah i can't i
can't let it go because he already i was
putting out fires all the way around
here
stopping it from going towards the house
meanwhile all the cars were on fire he
said
so it was burning on the wood down low i
didn't have any water
he had one barrel with a little water in
it he tried using that it didn't work
then he grabbed the only liquid he had
left cans of bud light
when i ripped up the sheet metal it had
a nail
so i was just shaking it up popping it
just and spraying them
popping it out and grabbing another one
he said my buddies all teased me about
drinking water beer and i said hey
save my shop hey it ain't water beer bud
light's the best beer
little said firefighters arrived soon
after he used his beard to extinguish
the flames at his shop
what an og right look at him look at him
but literally
yeah oh yeah he looks like he looks like
he's drinking that bud light
and they got the bud light cans he's
literally got a 36 case that's how you
know somebody likes bloodlines
you don't buy a six-pack you don't buy a
12-pack you don't buy a 24-pack you buy
a 36 case
when you get the 36 case you're a
professional well he i i just don't know
we should we should get uh
we should get um but like the sponsor
i i'd sit here crack beers every morning
a little little liquid can't be drinking
in the morning
why not unacceptable okay what's next
that's it you don't have any jokes today
i didn't have time because he rushed me
okay guys do you have a joke no no jokes
it's your birthday
i'll get one what do you call santa no
we already did that one
no we don't like that one all right what
do you call meditating wolf
don't say paulina a meditating wolf yeah
asleep aware of wolf
oh i was close all right guys today is
plana's birthday
rather than sing or happy birthday what
i want you guys to do
is leave a comment what is the most
outrageous gift
that you think that i could get her for
her birthday i have not yet gotten her a
gift
and it is uh 11 46 when we were
recording this in the morning
so we have about 12 hours and 14 minutes
until the day is over
for me to get a gift so leave a comment
links would be appreciated
or a gift that i could get hurt we'll
see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends while while
she's trying to get rich to us let's
just try to get our lunch money right
polina 24 years old today
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to
point six percent interest on a deposit
in an interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling
in the comments and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends